and you have no previous
foreign language learning experience
starting to learn a new language for the
first time can be a
really challenging task even if you are
motivated things are not easy at
all at first too much motivation and
little direction usually leads to
a full bookshelf  of
language books without using a phone full of
unopened applications and a
learning program that is everywhere that is to
say if you spend some time
learning instead most of your time is
spent thinking or rather worrying
you worry  by yourself asking
questions like what resources or
what resources should I start with when should I
start how often should I
spend learning how long
each of my learning sessions should take
you've probably found it difficult to
answer most of these
questions especially if  you do not
have external help normally you can
count on a teacher p  For it to give you
solutions but if you learn in a
self-taught way you only have the help
that you can give yourself
but they do not have to be that way with the
right guide and the right plan you can
learn any language even from
the comfort of your home away from the
classroom  Hello, I'm a great guy. I'm a
language coach who speaks 14 languages, including
Spanish. I work with people from all over the
world to help them achieve their
dreams of learning languages. On this channel,
I share tips and techniques that you can
use to learn languages
. more  fun and more effective i
would like to share three simple steps
you can put into practice right now
to help you start learning a
new
language the smart way
we start
step number 1 get the
right resources when you are starting to
study a language the most obvious of  what
to worry about is which learning resources to
use it doesn't take more
than a quick google search to  To
realize that for just about any
language you want to learn there are hundreds
of books, apps, courses, podcasts,
flashcards, and more all
aimed at helping you learn this
language. This may sound like a good thing,
but the sheer amount of
learning materials available makes it
impossible.  navigate between them and choose
which ones are really ideal for your
own needs so despite
the large number of resources
most people get stuck at this
stage and get stuck without being able to
move forward well it is true that there are many
things that you could possibly find
In many of these linguistic resources,
I recommend that you focus on
resources that have two characteristics
in particular. When you go to choose a
linguistic resource, look for it to be
understandable, that is, to have a
language that is in accordance with a level of the language of
the language you are studying and  the
resource has to be interesting that is to
say that  present content that
is attractive to you, it is more likely
that resources that meet these two
conditions will keep you
interested and with a sufficient level of challenge and
commitment and that
your level of interest will also be maintained
for a longer time, which will allow you to
learn the most  As far as possible
in my experience I have found that
learning materials with
authentic bilingual texts in my target
language most often meet the
understandable and interesting criteria
this goes for me and the hundreds of
hundreds of language learners I
personally train
because  bilingual texts are so important
because having the text both in
your target language and in your native language
or in a language you know well will
help you compare and contrast the
structure of both languages this compa
ison will help you gradu
lly understand how each language works
in  relationship with the other
this type of comparison is something that
h  You'll get into your head with or without a
bilingual text anyway but having the
texts in front of you makes it a
smoother and more painless process as a
beginner you'll want to look for
bilingual texts that include short,
natural dialogue in your target language along with
audio from  those dialogues even better if
the dialogues also include things like
a vocabulary list and
simple grammar explanations these
additional tools will help you
quickly clarify any words or
grammatical points that are difficult to understand
just by looking at both texts there are
several resources on the market today  day
they have all the features I
have described but personally I really like to
use the which is the a simile series
just for this purpose so milk is a
French company that offers
language textbooks in a wide range
of language combinations these textbooks
text are full of short
and funny dialogues
I have enjoyed in many  the different languages
have learned if you cannot find
simile in your language do not hesitate to lo
k in the description of this video where
I will leave you a link to the langu
ge resources page that I have on my website where
you can find many other resou
ces step
umber 2  get organized another important thing to
keep in mind if you want to
start learning a language successfully
is to get organized and stay organized
from the beginning contrary to what
you might think
language learning is a marathon it is not something you
can or should do for a few
weeks or months to reach the level you
want and then lie down to do the trick if
you don't use the language you lose it so it
is extremely important that before
you start you prepare yourself to learn
every day for a long period
of time there are three important aspects
that you have  to fulfill you must create a
learning space
to an irregular learning schedule and
cultivate a strong mentality
for me it is  learning space i make
sure i keep for example an area
of my room clean organized and free
f distractions where i can sit e
ery day and learn langu
ges i learn in this same place every day t
train my brain that this i
the place where learning ha
pens  your learning space
can be anywhere you
want however i recommend that you
try to keep it as free of
distractions as possible and learn in
this same place all the time for my
learning schedule i try to
keep things consistent and organized
too i especially learn to  the same
time every day and almost always
for the same amount of time this
helps make learning a habit
for added benefit i
do it at the time of day when i have the
most energy so i can concentrate
better and easier to  your
learning schedule aspires to dedicate
daily at least 30 between 30 and 45
m  minutes in the strip where you feel
more awake
try not to skip it be constant if you
fail one day at least try not to
skip more than two days in a row as you
run the risk of breaking completely
with your learning habit under my
way of thinking there is  to focus
on discipline not motivation the
truth is we can't count on
motivation because sometimes some
days we have enough energy how to
do everything and other days it's not we can't
find anything to do as we
embark on a challenging process  in the
long term such as
language learning motivation usually
ebbs and flows in unpredictable ways
which means you can rarely
plan to have it when you need it
instead of motivation i trust
discipline discipline when you have
discipline it's all about showing up
the days you feel like it or you don't feel like it
is about dedicating time and effort
even if you don't see the results  what
do you expect in a word it is about
coherence that if you notice it is a
fundamental part of my learning arsenal
my learning program and my way of
thinking if you feel that you have little
discipline you may wonder
how you can achieve it too
I will present you below  a
strategy that I have used often and
that you can try yourself if you are not
motivated enough to start
a difficult task how to learn a
language for example you can build
discipline by developing a ritual a
ritual is a simple routine that you can
practice every time you leave
start studying and give your brain to
think okay now let's study
your ritual can be anything but you
prefer short and
meditative activities that you can do in any
particular place before starting
each of my language learning sessions
I like  do a minute
of breathing exercises
walk around the room for a minute
and  sitting at the table where I am going to
study once I have done my
breathing and walking exercises
yes sitting is the signal to start
learning it sounds simple and it is but these
types of rituals can be quite
effective to start studying
even when the  motivation is low if you
develop the habit of starting to
study even when you don't feel like it
then you are cultivating the discipline
that will be an essential tool
throughout your learning journey
step number 3 reflect on your
progress every day
learning a language is a process
for long-term growth even though you are
learning every day the
steady progress you are making can be
difficult or impossible to see if you can't
see your progress it can be easy to get
demotivated and although I said before I don't
trust motivation I think it's
important to be careful  with
demotivation
if left unchecked demotivation
often causes people to give up and
d  avoid learning at all to avoid
the trap of demotivation it is
important to make your progress visible and
review it regularly personally i
do this by keeping a
language learning notebook now i say
notebook but what i really
mean is a space to write
about learning activities
language learning does not have to be a
physical notebook or diary in fact i often use
google docs just for this purpose
every day in my
language learning notebook i write down the
language learning activities i
have done that day for the languages
ch  which I am a beginner these are
usually activities that listen to reading and
translation linked to my
two-way translation method which is what
I personally use to start
any language beyond the list of
activities I also ask myself questions
that help me reflect on the
quality of  my learning
of this day these include questions
like
dis  result of my
current learning activities i find them
too easy too difficult or
just not challenging enough
can i add or remove something to make
these activities more effective is there
anything i can do to better adapt
these activities to the language i am
learning
ask myself these questions  prevents me from coming back
indulges me in my
learning activities and helps me improve over
time reflected in this way
helps me not only to keep track
of my language skills but
also to develop strategies and
techniques for learning languages ok there you have
t now you have  learned the three
simple steps that you can put into
practice today to start
learning any language if you are
interested in getting more information
on how to start learning new
languages on your own click on the link
hat I have left in the description of th
s video you will find  a link to my
new  online course that teaches the
ins and outs of my own
bidirectional translation method the course is
in english but all the videos are
subtitled in spanish and all the
extra material is in spanish so
you can enjoy the course even
if you don't speak english well yet as
always thank you  for seeing me and happy
language learning
[Music]